I
things that I like about my profession
about development specifically is that
it's kind of constantly evolving and
it's moving route fairly fast I think
compared to other things I love my job
because I can do everything I have in my
hat and create stuff that other people
can see because you only need the
problem I like JavaScript so anything
that has to do with JavaScript
immediately excites me there's no right
way to do things I think a note in
particular people keep inventing new
ways of doing stuff and everybody goes
oh we could be doing it that way or we
could be doing it this way and nobody's
really sure like what's the best way and
that's my favorite thing about it is
it's still constantly changing I really
love developing software and helping
others I'm also instructor and I love
combining the two where I've depends on
experience and it can go to people and
explain stuff that really works at the
community I mean as I talked about in my
talk was I love the community is why I
stick with the web and wife stuff with
continuing to push it forward because I
think it's really inclusive and really
easy and approachable to get started
with and in case you to bring in more
people from different disciplines I love
the ability to write something on my
laptop and publish it to the world and
have an impact on people and help their
feedback as a researcher I get a lot of
flexibility I get to play with new
things and
more ideas I love being able to work on
something with other people that in the
end has impact and being able to help
people with what we do with technology
is really thing that I enjoy most about
being insulted
it's a very good event I really the
atmosphere is good food is dudes the
people are all friendly and the talks
are very interesting self I love it it's
great yeah great vibe really nice
location really nice shady and I really
like to roof here where you can watch
the water from below event so far has
been really fun it's been really clusive
maniacally just Co driven but people
driven which is something I really like
and really hold dear I mostly why I like
coming to JS comp offense really it's
about how people come together unike is
not just the talks but how we meet up
with people afterwards even like after
parties or the workshops beforehand and
it's just so much fun and I really
commend everyone put it together
you